this is a production of cornell
university
yeah let's get started here uh thanks
everybody welcome to the seventh episode
this year the cornell turf show our
fourth week doing this
uh been been great a couple weeks sunny
and warm getting to talk about people
out playing and then there's snow on the
ground here for us significant so
um maybe a couple of you guys joining
from from indoors this morning
um today's guest dr johnny ingrajado of
uconn
uh we're gonna do a lot of talking about
roots today and and for our live
attendees again we have a poll question
um just kind of what what uh grass do
you guys have on your green spent poe
mix other so if you got time uh fill
that poll out
um but otherwise we'll get started uh
one of our previous guests on the show
rich buckley for those who can see on
the screen we got a nice picture of rich
in the lab what's what's he up to there
frank
well rich is a busy guy carl thanks for
uh thanks for hosting and thank you guys
all for
um uh joining us today whether it's live
via video or uh we've even made this
into a podcast so for those of you not
watching on you know news channel six or
something you can't
necessarily see the uh slides here but
uh
rick's a long time rich is a long time
supporter of all the things we've done
to try to help with diagnostics and of
course i think
had a bit of an influence on our guests
uh career
uh during his time there so let's just
start out with some images carl you know
i i sort of scoured twitter
uh weekly looking for things and and you
know projects are wrapping up whether
you're washing ball washers or or fixing
up ball washers or putting in new
bathrooms
uh people are getting new equipment
delivered and and here's a
a shot a whole bunch of pumps being
pushed into triplex
uh mowers on their way for delivery uh
of course spring is springing uh and
sprung in many areas
and and so many golf courses are uh
fortunate to have
areas where it makes sense to have these
beautiful flowering trees i know we have
them on a lot of the
state park golf courses certainly the
ones down at beth page that i'm most
familiar with but
i thought i'd share you know if you're
waking up this spring morning like we
are in upstate new york with some snow
i share uh some pictures from my friends
down under in australia i have a lot of
close friends that
uh i've developed over the years of
visiting there and
here's a shot from an area just the
northwest of sydney
uh this is a golf course in the lower
left taken about a week ago
and this is what it looked like uh just
last week after the flooding went
through they got
essentially three quarters of their
annual rainfall
uh in a day um so
you know if you think you're having a
bad day uh you know how about these four
guys uh you know
trying to get it done so you know uh
before i pass it back to your car for
the bmp minute today
and we go through my little spiel and
get to johnny let me remind everybody
about this very exciting project we've
got on got going on in a partnership
with the
new york state pollution preventative
prevention institute which is of course
funded by the
new york state dec this is based at the
rochester institute of technology much
like the new york state ipm program
funded by the but funded by new york
state is is based at cornell university
and we're partnering with them and our
old pal rick slattery the long time
former superintendent at locust hill
golf club that we did the wash pad with
years ago
i just want to remind you we've been at
this for about a year and a half a year
a little over a year now
in earnest we've collected the data done
a bunch of work trying to improve the
adoption
of best management practices essentially
west of i-81
and it's uh culminated recently in in
website
uh a website that's housed at the
pollution prevention institute and again
for those of you watching on
news channel six you can see uh the
website here
uh you have the ability to subscribe uh
and reach out to us maybe you have a
question about what this is like to
learn a little bit more
i'd encourage you to uh participate in
this
there are some resources that you'll see
highlighted there and one in particular
that i will pass it over to carl to talk
about is this wonderful placard
that's now been launching and available
through twitter through the website you
can download print out copies we're
about to mail out a bunch carl
how did we come up with this uh idea to
release this poster and then take us
through the minute
yes so we spent most of last year uh
again with rick slattery's health uh
just randomly surveying a bunch of golf
courses in our region
asking about a bunch of uh best
management practices
and from that data we learned okay you
know maybe we should focus on certain
practices
uh that people aren't doing so much and
let's condense the information down into
a digestible format
and so this is what we came up with this
infographic poster
really simple short hitting tips we
aimed this to be
very easy to look at not too much text
on here just really quick hitting
easily digestible best management
practices so
for those who have been on the with us
on the show for the last couple weeks
we've been taking certain
pieces of this expanding it out doing a
tip of the day
uh and so our tip of the day today is uh
irrigation run time
everybody does this in minutes right and
that's understandable you got to program
the irrigation system in minutes but
not a whole lot of people from from when
we're going around talking to people
know how that that run time in minutes
translates to inches
um and so it's always been kind of
confusing for me i didn't come from turf
but
uh you know we reg we look at rainfall
and we say hey rained an inch yesterday
or hey we got a half an inch but when we
talk about irrigation oh i ran it for 10
minutes last night i ran it for 12
minutes and not everyone that i've seen
knows how that minute number translates
to inches so our bmp tip of the day
hey just kind of kind of get a feel for
hey how much
how many inches did i put down if i ran
a 10 minute cycle last night
that seems like something we should know
when we're looking at eet data and
macbook transpiration again we're
measuring that in inches
if we're replacing that amount of water
we should probably know um
how many inches we're applying to so to
today's bmp tip of the day
you know throw some ketchups out there
uh you can even do this with a soil
moisture meter if you run it for 10
minutes
hey probe before and after and see what
percent increase you got
um so so that's our bmp tip of the day
thanks carl
i uh i turned my um uh camera off i'm
might be having a little bit of internet
trouble carl so keep me honest if you
can't hear me uh
jump shout out at me right away okay
so uh before we get to john our
conversation uh
about uh turfgrass disease especially
root issues early on
um john's got a lot of expertise in a
lot of areas here
let's start with just the weather in
case you're wondering it's warmer than
normal even though there's snow on the
ground outside
you can see some areas around buffalo
out on even on the east end of long
island you're looking at two weeks ahead
of normal
where john is out there in stores
connecticut two weeks ahead of normal
uh creeping into two weeks almost three
weeks ahead of normal
in and around the uh buffalo area as
well so in case
lest anybody wonder that the last couple
of cooler days
might be what we're having uh overall
we've been warmer
we've also been persistently dry uh
except for uh where rich buckley is on
thursdays every place but where rich
buckley is on thursdays uh typically has
been dry this is a look at
percent normal precipitation um
you know across the region over the last
month
uh not just short of a week so this is
about a week ago these maps update uh
every thursday and they don't update
until after we do this webinar so
unfortunately with these things
we're looking at some dry weather but to
clarify a lot of these things
aren't going to change much by the
little bit of rainfall that just might
have went through recently
well one of the things that did go
through recently was
uh uh warmer temperatures and drier
conditions and again
chatting with rich uh this morning he's
starting to get some winter damage
on annual bluegrass a little bit on
kentucky bluegrass
into the labs as warm temperatures come
up
things start greening up you can see uh
maybe what's not going to green up or
sometimes poe starch green
but because it gets dry uh dies out now
again it's been a little bit wet the
last recent
uh week or so up until just uh
yesterday uh you know you're getting one
two inches again
into new jersey is soaking wet looks
like even where
out where johnny is it's pretty wet out
in stores
connecticut uh but in general everybody
had a little bit of rainfall the last
week but that's not going to
solve all the problems what it seemed to
do
john and let me let me start by uh
chatting with this thing about this
thing first
uh this popped up on the radar um rich
said he got a bunch of samples that came
in the lab and i immediately
you know go to the uh the publication
out of kentucky that that uh uh you know
paul coke and bruce and everybody's
contributed to over the last several
years
and i wonder how much you know about
this is one of those weird
new diseases in my mind when i look at
the chemicals
uh there's a lot of uh a subscript
a superscripts there which means a lot
of companies wrote two w
two double e uh formulations uh these
are epa
emergency use guidelines that these
products will work
on this particular disease and then a
lot of the combination products there's
not a lot of data on them if you look at
the efficacy there this
l indicates very limited data where we
have
we do have good data on a lot of them
but a lot of them
are are two double e emergency sorts of
things
and john let me bring in here for a
minute and ask you
uh what do you think what what do you
want to tell me about why tia patch
controlling it and worrying about it
with with the current weather conditions
um i mean it's definitely i mean it's a
perennial issue um i mean folks that are
managing poet it looks like a number of
our
uh participants today are poe growers um
yeah i mean it seems to be uh it seems
to be
an issue that that people deal with
pretty frequently uh in the spring i
mean
one thing i would say about it is
in most cases it's generally not a
devastating disease i mean
you get some yellow rings and it's kind
of one of those first diseases that we
see every spring and so everyone's fired
up about it
um generally i don't find it terribly
you know devastating but it can be
problematic because
it's a it's a fungus that's working down
there in the thatch
um and you can get some kind of
degradation there in the thatch and you
can kind of get some softness
in that ring which you know obviously
can have an
impact on ball roll in some cases when
particularly when it's really severe so
um so it can be a challenge um
you know regarding uh when we see it
it's you know it's something that we'll
start to start to see showing up when
when the turf starts to break dormancy
uh i noticed it i mean you brought it up
that rich is seeing it in the lab down
there
i'm seeing it our field showing up um
and you'll see it until
until temperatures you know consistently
break 75 degrees we'll
we'll see it you know we'll see at 75
even 80 degrees so
and i and i think your comment about um
the one problem many
many would have with it um would be
uh that it causes that pitting
that depression um that will disrupt
ball roll i i actually think you're
right i'm not sure i've ever seen it be
lethal
uh but i have seen it um i have seen it
uh caused those depressions which
are ball roll issues so listen i want to
get to this next topic because i brought
it up with
rich last week i know this is something
you've spent a fair amount of your
career working on as well
and and that's early season anthracnose
um
you know one of the things i've read uh
especially something i think you got
interviewed last year
you called this uh particular problem
johnny a chronic disease
one that you just sort of learn uh to
live with
and i guess for in the places where it
is chronic
um where does early season stuff
fit in um what do you usually tell
people
you know why they're seeing it or what's
it about and then
how to manage it uh
yeah i mean i think the early season
stuff i i really like that the early
season stuff probably to
maybe an indication of of areas where
you kind of have a lot of moisture
sitting around in the canopy
um you know stuff that was probably
hanging around in the fall
kind of remained wet in the fall and
kind of you know
maybe we had some you know moderate
temperatures over the winter and
and it's just kind of moisture hanging
around in there and the fungus is kind
of continuing to work away
um i mean in most cases
you know i you know be curious to hear
what people's experiences are but
in most cases i i kind of see the the
early spring stuff is kind of a
transitional
um it kind of comes but it's not the big
flare-up that we see
kind of showing up into june and july
so i mean and and because
because it is showing up at that time of
year oftentimes it's early enough where
we can get poa to kind of recover and
fill back in so
um you know i think once we kind of
start our our fungicide programs and
turf starts to grow again a lot of times
we can kind of overcome that
that kind of early season stuff okay
well thank you for
making the transition really easy as we
start our conversation about
you know what i know you've been playing
around with for a while now we've talked
we talked about it last year
probably around a year ago this time it
comes up every spring as it relates to
soil temperature and timing of fungicide
applications and the kinds of problems
we have
with roof path root pathogens now you
know what's really interesting
is if you look at our two-inch soil
temperatures
uh as modeled and reported on our turf
grass forecast website which art builds
for the
you know pulls from the northeast
climate center we were actually
uh a little bit warmer last week
than we are this week it looks like it's
gotten warmer
further south more uniformly but the
soils are still
in the low 50s john and and really
that's the launching point for me here
because
you know rich buckley likes to remind me
that the fungi don't read the textbooks
and so they don't really know what
they're you know well it says in the
textbook it does this
but it seems like this is one of those
fungi that we really
tied to uh soil temperature activity
is it something that if i've had a
chronic problem with
it's good to get out there early and do
this now
maybe while it's drier for summer patch
and fairy ring
take all i would have had a treat it may
be best in the fall but let's start with
the ones that i'm timing up for spring
applications can i be too early
yeah i would say you can certainly be
too early um
you know summer patch for an example um
these fungicides only work when the
fungus
is is actually actively growing um so
you know these fungicides that you apply
them they're going to degrade and so
if you apply them too early they're
going to break down they're going to
degrade
uh they're going to be metabolized
inside the plant and if that happens
before the fungus is actually
actively growing and infecting the plant
then you just wasted that application
um so so certainly and you know i think
it's great to look at soil temperature
maps like you just pulled up there
um you know it's good to monitor those
things but you know i think that we need
to be
we need to be mindful of it's not just
that one it's not just like that blip
where soil temperatures all sudden shoot
up to 65 degrees for a day
um that's that's not biologically that
relevant
uh we need we need those soil
temperatures to kind of stabilize
and so you know i encourage people to
monitor daily you know look at the
you know those kinds of computer-based
things that's that's a great way to kind
of start knowing when you need to go out
there and physically track your own soil
temperatures on a daily basis
that's right perfect and and so how much
do we know about
how long these things will last let's
let's start with first off we talked
about it last week i've talked about it
with other folks
we have a chronic problem with making
sure we get enough water in
right get enough water on it uh the
fungicide to get it down to where
they're active
how much do we know about once it gets
there
roughly how long it's protecting us how
many you know is it like pre-emergent
herbicides john where you know i get it
on
early it wears out i might have still
germination later that i've got to worry
about
how many how much am i you know waiting
till it gets to that temperature and
then
knowing i got to do it three weeks later
and then three weeks later and three
weeks later when
when can i start thinking about how long
these things are going to last
no weed scientists but from what i do
know
yeah i think we know about as much about
how long a fungicide app class as well
as we do a pre-emergent herbicide right
i mean those guys
it's always like well it's a really
rainy year this year so you're going to
have to tighten up that
you know the same thing is true with
fungicides i mean to answer your
question
no you know we don't know exactly how
long it's going to last it's
dependent on a lot of factors i would
say if we have
warm and wet conditions those things
probably aren't going to last as long
because you've got microbial activity
breaking down fungicides you got the
plant growing
and so the fungicide gets metabolized
and broken down inside the plant
and and you've got just degradation
through environmental things so
generally speaking though i mean i think
that the the recommendations of
you know high rates of of these
different fungicides on a
21-day interval 28-day
interval maybe um generally provide
fairly reliable uh control
but the challenge comes you know i mean
i talked to a number of superintendents
like
we applied early you know we did it at
the right time and i still get this
breakthrough
what's the problem here and you know i i
think it just it's
these root pathogens are really really
challenging to control
our fungicides are really
you know have a really high affinity to
bind and get locked up in organic matter
and soil and that's why we need those
high rates
in order to control suppress the disease
because
we need to put as much of the of the
active ingredient as we can
into that soil system for the hope that
it's going to get
actually to the root um and and get
taken up by the plant and if you know if
you're using those low rates
you know the chances are that that
you're likely going to just get it
locked up and the roots aren't actually
going to get it so it's
you got to use the high rates and and
you know the latest research
that jim kearns at north carolina state
has been finding is
you know if there's there's always
debate about whether i got to water it
in or whether i
use the high carrier volume and he's
he's putting out some data now that
really
really kind of re you know confirms what
we've always
taught and believed is that you know it
is important to get down a good
carrier volume or to water it in uh with
you know an eighth of an inch
or you know i one of the things i i
always think about whenever we're trying
to solve soil problems
is that you're never going to get like
eradication of this organism there's
always going to be some level
of infection you're going to live with
even with a good
high rate drench there are likely to be
escapes either because of
intervals or population levels that
simply
you know can't be managed and again
those things are
sort of consistent the same conditions
that cause the breakdown
of the fungicide enhance the infection
and and populations oftentimes of these
root pathogens and so
it you know it brings up the question
that you've studied which is
how do you deal with the sort of
ancillary stress
that somewhat determines how much root
loss i can live with right and i
i think you identified you know over the
years we've talked about the air
forcation and the manganese applications
in particular
but when you people come back to you and
say you know i think i did everything
right
you know and it's still not working they
feel like they're at the high rate
are you are they saying that they're
also fixing these root
problems uh you know these these uh sort
of other aspects and they're still
having this problem
or is that one of those things that's a
lingering issue that they just
sort of no matter what they do they're
just going to have summer patch
i i mean i think that some of those
things are hard to address you know it's
easier to
change your chemical program quickly
it's harder to remediate
long-standing soil soil issues so
you know i think it takes time and i
think if you know if you
if you can you know get your root if you
can really maximize root health
through good cultivation practices
through making sure that you're you know
that you're making these levels are
sufficient
um you know i think that in the long
term i think that those things are going
to help
um so um
yeah i think it's it's it's just harder
to see those things take an
immediate impact probably well and and a
lot of times you know
i think about especially you know
high-end guys high-end golf courses with
uh
bempo fairways and nice lush kentucky
bluegrass
maybe some poe annual rough uh that
they're keeping nice
uh you know right now it's gonna get
going soon it'll get going
i wonder where sometimes about the
taller grass the fairways and the rough
areas
uh john those those soil issues are
they're larger it's not like you're just
trying to fix
putting green stuff i'm wondering about
these
these larger soil areas what about
kentucky bluegrass uh
have we made enough headway uh with
resistance
in some of the bluegrass types that that
really should be your first line of
defense
um i there's definitely been progress
there i mean i don't
uh there are um you know there's a
number of cultivars
um and you know one that
has been kind of studied for for the
past several years is like our vet
um has has shown some pretty good uh
summer patch tolerance but
um i was just looking at the at the
latest ntep trial work and and it looks
like there's some additional ones so
barbette still continues to be good but
there's some additional ones and then
unfortunately the names are slipping
maybe right now but um
but but there has been some progress
there and i and i and i'm encouraged by
that because i
you know i came from rutgers i i
appreciate some good genetics
um it makes everything easier you know i
mean should it be our first thing
i don't know that i don't know that it's
the resistance level is
that strong yet to where it's like put
it to bed
kind of an issue it's not like smut
right
in kentucky bluegrass right we don't
talk about smut anymore but
um but for summer patch um it's not
quite
that great but it's definitely a big
improvement and i think that when you
have the opportunity
uh if you have a perennial historical
problem with that disease
you should really be trying to take
advantage when you have those
opportunities to use new seeds to look
at resistant ones
okay and so one thing that doesn't seem
to have any uh resistance uh
issues where we have any resistance to
it
is a pythium root rot it seems to rear
its head
every year when rainfall levels get
really high of course we're dry now but
um i i was alarmed to see uh promotional
emails coming through my email box
recently
from uh you know suppliers throughout
the region
who will remain nameless so i don't get
letters sent to the lawyers at cornell
who are promoting preventative pythium
root rot
uh applications and listen
i don't know a lot about you know i
don't know a lot about a lot
uh especially when it comes to these
sorts of things but when it comes to
pythium
that seems a little bit of a stretch to
be worrying about having to make
preventative pythium
pythium root rot applications in the
next couple of weeks uh
what say you john um i agree with you
100
i mean i think that uh
there i see a lot i see a big push for
for similar types of programs every
spring
and you know i'm not going to say that
that everyone's wasting their time with
them
um but i think
to to just assume that everybody needs
to do this i mean
it's a situation where if you have a
history
of pythium root rot and you know like
you've gotten lab tests and you get
those results back and it's like the
same
wet areas every year where you get it
and you get them in the spring
or you get them in early summer showing
up then
yeah those those for those folks i think
that
you know treating preventatively
probably is you know something you ought
to be considering
well or maybe they're fixing the
drainage what do you do well yeah
yeah of course of course yeah um
but a couple of things i mean before we
even i mean i agree with you 100
on that um but i think an important
thing to remember is that
you know it's not like we're just it's
not like take all patch or summer patch
we've got one single pathogen out there
when it comes to pythium root rots
there's a lot of different pythium
species
some are cool weather grower you know
infecting
pythiums others are warm season warm
weather
types of pathogens and so to say that
you need to
you know go out you know even if you get
a soil you know
diagnostic lab tests saying that you've
got a pythian root rot
you know you got to think about when did
you see that did you see it in the
middle of the summer or did you see it
like towards the end
um because in some cases you know maybe
the optimal
preventive timing is in the summer
months not right now
you know just like we were talking about
before you can be too early
you know so where do where does our use
of phosphites come into this discussion
because obviously they come up a little
bit as a treatment
uh that a lot of guys are on and i know
uh john kaminski a number of years ago
was was uh
you know rambling around finding
pythiums that phosphites didn't control
do we have any of that going on with the
variety of
pythium species we have in the root
zones ones that are might
might simply not be affected very much
by phosphite are we
potentially selecting uh for that
particular pythium with the way we use
phosphites nowadays
yeah i mean there's uh you know john
actually is continuing to kind of do
some of that work
um and and it does appear to be the case
um there do seem to be
um you know through through the very
consistent use of phosphites or
or or signature type uh products um
yeah it does seem that yeah we are
protect perhaps selecting for because
because those products are pretty broad
spectrum pythium materials
it seems that there are some weaker
pythiums
uh because i said there's a lot of
species so there's some weaker ones out
there
um that might not be as sensitive to
those and so through the continued use
we're selecting for those weaker ones
and uh and it does seem to cause uh
you know kind of a low uh canopy
level blight um and it typically you
know it shows up during the summer
months
um but fortunately what what
uh john has seen and what others have
seen is that it is pretty easy to check
up um so um you know they seem to be
very sensitive to some of our
traditional pythium products like segway
or banal
and so um so you know just kind of one
or two applications of one of those
products
if if that's what you're dealing with
does seem to make a difference
perfect carl we're getting close brother
any questions for us
before we uh thank john and sign off
yeah no questions from the group but but
uh i did have a comment john
uh a couple weeks ago again we were
talking about these church applications
uh and jason griffiths asked a good
question you know can i throw a wedding
agent in there or can i just poke a hole
and maybe that allows me to get some
more of that application down into the
root zone easier
any comments on on maybe one of those
two methods getting it down there easier
yeah i mean i you know i think we might
have even talked about that last year
when we were talking about
uh summer patch but i i you know i
haven't seen
some so i haven't seen really great data
on that yet but i am a firm believer
that you know
kind of pre-loading uh your soil system
with a wetting agent is probably really
important to ensuring that you get
good fungicide movement down um you know
we've all seen those pictures you know
like with the finger flow
so you know if you have fingered flow
of water movement through your soil
profile well that's where your
fungicides going
and so if you've got you know
preferential movement then
you've you're potentially not protecting
all of your roots and so by getting a
wedding agent in there uniformly wetting
that profile
you're hopefully going to get more
uniform fungicide coverage
perfect thanks for the comment carl john
thanks for taking the time to join us
really appreciate you uh
doing this again and best michelle and
the kids
carl uh another fast 30 minutes in the
books brother
yep another one in the books and a quick
announcement um
for those who are familiar last year
there was a documentary uh i think it's
the bar stool golf guys did it with the
wing wingfoot
steve rabadoo of behind the scenes uh
for the us open and they're actually
releasing another one tonight
i think it's at eight o'clock but but i
did see some in their trailer some
images of national golf links in there
so for you guys who are
really interested in maybe a
behind-the-scenes look of some really
high level
golf course management you might want to
check that out tonight but um
yeah other than that uh we'll get
everybody out of here john thank you
thank you again for your time
as always it's been the cornell turf
show fastest 30 minutes in turf see you
guys next week
all right good time good luck everybody
thanks have a good season
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu